When you think of natural resources, maybe you think of forests, minerals or fertile soil.
Plants and animals can be precious resources too,...
...especially in regions with undeveloped rainforests like parts of Central America...
...or unique animals like East Africa.
But protecting these plants and animals is a big challenge.
Take the example of East Africa.
Many East African animals face the threat of poachers,...
...people who steal animals to sell to collectors or kill them for their tusks or hides.
In addition, animals require land resources that people could use for farming or houses.
Protecting wildlife and setting aside land for animals to roam and graze is expensive,...
...and the nations of East Africa don't have any extra money.
So how can a country protect its wildlife resources and generate money and jobs for people?
The answer in part is ecotourism.
Ecotourism is a growing trend in the tourist industry.
Tourists spend their vacation with wildlife in the animals' natural habitat.
The money the tourists spend helps the host country's economy...
...and helps the host country acquire the money it needs to protect its wildlife.